you added some personal events of your
own life in the book anything that you
weighed and you decided you know I need
to this is an important part of telling
my story I know it's a bit personal but
I feel that other people need to know it
in some ways both the beginning of the
end of the book were not there
originally that that question of
recognizing the the privilege that I had
by having a family that loved culture
that loved film that valued education
that got me exposed and in a situation
where I had opportunity what was
something that came as I thought through
the process it wasn't part of the
original story and I felt was critical
to try to see the good fortune the
privilege that that that game I wouldn't
have finished the book frankly if I
hadn't resigned from the San Francisco
Film Society I had been working on it I
had tremendous help from anthony kaufman
but i put it aside and it was in that
break after i resigned or really even in
over the last few months of that job
that i finished the book and I felt that
that transition that design you know the
desire I had to say filmmaking will not
be my profession right that I can do
more good not making more films even
though I think I haven't made my best
work yet but by focusing on building a
film ecosystem and I felt this as a
mission right I felt this in my heart as
what got me out of bed in the morning
was my drive and I was very excited to
move to San Francisco and to work with
such a prestigious organize a
to advance film art and culture and it
was disappointing to me to kind of see
that there were legacy practices that
were in place that wouldn't really allow
that to happen or certainly not allow it
on the timeline that I initially went
into thinking i could do things so that
some ways broke my heart right and i
felt it was a necessary conclusion to
that choice of you know what I've made
70 films I'm at the height of my game I
feel better about making movies and I
ever have but even still I'm going to
leave the city that I love I'm going to
move to the west coast I'm going to take
a hiatus from producing because this is
what's needed and I think I people who
want to support me in doing it but it
wasn't so easy so I felt like I needed
to have that chapter to bookend it to
show that rocks are being that process
yet and in addition to that started to
do the intro to the next chapter you
know that then the decision to stay with
the plan of trying to build a a workable
sustainable ecosystem for a wider
diverse population of filmmakers and
film lovers to do that not in the
nonprofit sector but to do it through a
start-up which is where I am now
you